[Music]
thank you so much
this is such an amazing honor
everything that i do i do it with
intention of
hopefully um making someone else's
experience better
and making sure that the things that i
struggled with
um people that come after me um don't
have to struggle with as much
i come from a very difficult home
situation so
home is not necessarily somewhere it can
go to for support
um rather home comes to me for support
so
my first few years at mit i would have
to
work multiple campus jobs to be able to
send money back home
um and i would have to take time from
classes where i'd be like you know what
i can't go to this class this day
because i have to pick up extra shifts
and that's not uh an
experience that i think gets talked
about enough or
is understood enough for parents weekend
my freshman year
seeing everyone's parents coming to
campus
um sitting with them in classes all of
the events going on that weekend were
catered specifically to
students and their parents that made me
feel so so so lonely
because i couldn't afford to bring my
mom to come visit i didn't have the
family to come
and support me and even if i was able to
bring my mom she would have to stay with
me on campus because we don't have the
money for a hotel and things like that
and it was just a constant reminder that
weekend that
a lot of the people at mit had a very
different experience than i did prior to
mit
and dealt with a very different
day-to-day life
and we were able to create um an event
for
students whose parents can't make it or
family or guardians or loved ones just
can't make it to campus
um and you'd be surprised how many
students like there's so many
international students
families can make it so many students
who are low-income
who for different like issues just can't
have family here and that
for so long have felt this way but
mit had just not thought about this the
goal
of my work is to make sure that everyone
in the mit community especially those
who feel like they have been
underrepresented really do feel like
this
is their home as well that they find
their home
under the dome
you